I want to begin today by mentioning a virtual literary fact,
uh,
a story that does not happen,
one that only exists in the ass if of literature.
Uh,
it's a make believe but literatures make belief,
but that nevertheless suggestive of the enigmatic and even a prophetic powers of
literature.
In talking the last time about Cervantes,
his reaction to the publication of [inaudible] Quixote,
uh,
of which he learned when he was writing chapter 36 of his own second part,
we failed to mention a change he made in the donkey Hotez plants to distinguish
his own book from that of the impostor.
You may remember that in mentioning the possibility of a third,
Sally at the end of part one,
there is a reference to some journalists in Santa Rosa.
Where is it?
Yeah,
so they're also,
you'll have a handout to help you now.
You have it already.
We should have gotten to each one of you,
if not,
sorry,
Rosa
and uh,
uh,
at the beginning of Cervantes is part to,
it is against it.
The Don Quixote will go to Saragosa to,
to participate in the tournament,
which takes place during the celebration of St Georges de Saint George's,
the saint who was at night on April the 23rd.
This is where Don Quixote is headed as he sets forth for the third time.
But it so happens that [inaudible] Neda had also taken the cue from part one of
this Saragosa jousts and had his own Doki how they actually go and participate
in the tournament.
This was enough for Servantez to change Doki halters destination in mid novel
and have him divert toward Barcelona without passing through Saragosa,
which is what he does in the book.
Uh,
[inaudible] goes to start.
I also don't you hold this book.
We,
uh,
goes to Barcelona.
Okay.
This is all well good.
Uh,
another instances Sylvana does his reaction to the Apocrypha Quixote.
What's an event this could not have known of course,
is that April 23rd,
the day of those jobs would be the date of his own death,
so that he avoided knowingly.
Of course,
having the end of his book announced his own,
and
now this is all live.
Who say a speculation on my part of fiction making on my part,
but such implied coincidences make me wonder sometimes,
uh,
is literature always an evading or a postponement of death
that is more to the telling of stories then the telling of stories as shared
outside,
they knew when she told story after story night after night,
forestalling her own demise in the thousand and one nights.
Do you remember that Shit outside that tells stories to,
uh,
to avoid her being a slain.
So she tells stories to forestall her own death.
So in some
implicit way,
perhaps only in my overheated imagination,
this is what happens when it said Vantis has his character swerve away from
April the 23rd so much for that April the 23rd,
by the way,
said bad date for great writers.
And is the date on which Shakespeare also died same year?
I said,
well,
not exactly the same day,
close enough,
the same date because England and Spain used a different calendar.
So there was a difference of two or three days,
but April the 23rd is also the date of Shakespeare's death.
So there's something magical about April the 23rd,
so much.
So that Aleppo Carpentier,
the great Cuban writer about whom I have written a great deal also died on April
the 23rd centuries later.
So we should warn all riders,
not,
uh,
to take very seriously April the 23rd,
but I'm sure that some wishing to be as great as Advantis and Shakespeare or
Carpentier would take it and we'd rather just die on April the 23rd to,
uh,
to be as great as as they were.
So perhaps this is just,
uh,
an Monica device,
something to make you remember the date of [inaudible] death to which we'll
return when we read his farewell in the prologue to the trials of fussiness and
see his mom.
Yeah.
Now let us return to the issue of the new features of part two.
I remarked on the discussion among donkey halted the priest and the barber about
Spain's political situation and the Rv Trista's uh,
those,
uh,
who offered solutions to the problems at hand.
I remarked that the discussion should be seen in the context of my commentary on
the speech about arms on letters when I said that by the sixth things,
by the 16th century government had become the object of intellectual reflection,
uh,
and mentioned Machiavelli's the prince,
as a founding work of political science.
I also told you,
uh,
during the 16th century,
they were not a few books written about the education of the prince,
uh,
in which guidelines were offered about how to prepare a young man for,
for Kingship,
for being a ruler.
All of these preoccupations are in the background of this discussion among the
three characters.
What the discussion also indicates,
and this is very significant,
is that the Quixote part two is the first political novel
because the deals and incorporates current events,
uh,
such as the expulsion of the Maury scarf.
Okay.
Uh,
the Maurice goes where the Arabs who remained after the,
uh,
fall of Granola in 1492,
of course,
there were large communities of our apps in Spain and many remained and they
were,
uh,
by decree and by force,
compelled to,
uh,
bandwidth.
Not only their religion but their practices and so forth,
but the customs and stuff and they were expelled,
uh,
from Spain at the time,
but said vantage was writing part two of the Quixote.
And this,
uh,
this political event is incorporated into the novel.
This is why I say that the,
uh,
the day part two is the first political novel impact too.
There is also a bitter satire of the aristocracy and they're irresponsible ways
in the figures of the Duke and Duchess that you will meet later.
The satire of the [inaudible] is part of these political thematic and Doki is
acting like an attribute to is does.
He does remember the idea that he has on how to,
how to fight off the Turks,
uh,
is part of the critique of the nobility even if don't get healthy is a pathetic
and impoverished Evalgo.
But here he's trying to play the role of the arbitrary stuff.
This is what the king should do.
Another new factories that three or four of the initial chapters in part two
take place indoors,
be it in donkey haughtiness or in Saint Joe's house.
In contrast to part one,
a great deal of part two will take place indoors reflecting a more urban setting
in the novel,
you will have the village of a torso and Barcelona
ins will still play a role but not as important as one Palo [inaudible] in part
one.
And remember the holes in the roof of that in to be in Palo [inaudible] in was
almost to still be outdoors
here in second part.
And the,
in part two,
there will be houses,
mansions,
uh,
and uh,
cities,
uh,
like a torso,
which is merely a village.
And Barcelona,
which is a great city.
The novel,
the modern novel that develops from the Quixote will be essentially an urban jar
dealing with cities.
If you think of Balzac,
uh,
because in cities there is a,
there is,
uh,
there are more people engaged in playing,
different,
uh,
many roles and he's a thicker social or context.
So we can see in this development a movement toward the city in the novel
or the one could say that if the remote kernel of the novel of the modern novel
is Lassila Celestina about which I have talked many times,
that work already takes place in a city,
presumably Salamanca and although much of the picker risks takes place on the
road,
there are also cities in Lhasa Deion particularly in Deguzman Guzman,
they'll farace being indoors but also outdoors.
Most of the action of part two takes place at night
in the dark.
We had night episodes in part one,
the fooling hammers,
the fracas at the,
in the episode with a dead body,
but most of it takes place,
uh,
outdoors on the road,
on in day light,
not so in part two in the darkness will play an important role in several
episodes and there are two that actually take place on the ground in caves part
to us.
We will soon see is more baroque and the buildings and darkness contribute to
it.
Another development in part two is it's being scripted and performed in the
present.
Presumably as we read,
not in the past by see they're made they winning Haley and his translators.
It is ringing improvised on the go.
In addition and as already remarked,
many characters have read part one which serves as the background as a model as
it were for part two.
We already had had intimations of this in part one these the novel being
scripted and written as the novel takes place in the episode of the dead body.
When sanctuary gives Gnocchi halted the moniker the night of the thorough full
countenance.
The Evalgo remark that the writer most of put the idea in Saint Joe's head,
so just in the novel has been written as the performance,
but now now we have the plans and preparations for the action being discussed by
the characters,
particularly by sound Song Carrasco in part two part one plays a role that the
romances of jewelry play in part one let me repeat that because it's a bit
convoluted in part two,
part one place the role that the romances of chivalry played in part one
it is the original that the characters who have read at one donkey holder to
reproduce an act according to it.
Okay,
so a new larger mirror has been added to the play of mirrors already present in
part one don't be haughty belongs to a previous fiction that the new characters
who have read it want him to be true to
everything now is part of donkey.
This fiction
sandstone Carrasco is the most important new character to emerge in part
through.
He has a harsh sounding name.
Sounds got cool.
Okay.
He's a tomboy.
The song of Bartolo Carrasco who studied in Salamanca and has come back with a
bachelor's degree.
He is another of several uh,
university graduates in the Quixote,
the first being the priest,
but the most memorable one so far.
Good soft Domo,
if you remember,
this is a reflection of the importance of university is a university in Spain.
You in this period,
particularly after the work of Cardinal Francisco,
he managed,
this is narrows about who you have read in Elliot who founded the University of
Alcoa.
There is a mild sat higher of intellectuals in the figure of Samsung Carrasco as
they,
as there is in that of,
of the priest in part one and throughout part to the priest was the graduate of
a Lesser University,
not quite Salamanca.
He's called Samsung to begin the part of the south tower.
He said he's called Samsung,
but it's quite small,
isn't all whose daughter giant like the sands Samsung of the,
of the Bible.
Uh,
but most importantly he's a jokester,
prankster,
and an avid reader of romances of chivalry and particularly of part one of the
Quixote,
which he seems to know by heart to judge by comments he makes.
He was also a reader of [inaudible],
so sound song,
spent his time at Salamanca Reading Literature,
not studying theology,
which is what he was supposed to do.
He is the counterpart of the Canon of Toledo in part one,
but he's not a solemn and pedantic like the Canon was is like the opposite
sign song is a reader of part one.
Part one again is to him,
but the romances of chivalry when to Don Quixote.
He wants to reenact it.
Josa Gokey hotel wanted to reenact and dramatize the Debra masters of chivalry.
He's planned to cure don Quixote is to defeat him within the fiction of his
madness like the priest and the barber in part one,
but in doing so,
he will become another Quixote.
He's double in a truer sense.
Then all the others in part one,
if part one was held together by the overarching plot of the persecution and
capture of Don Quixote by the Holy Brotherhood,
the barber and the priest in part to that role is played by sandstones schemes
to bring donkey Quixote back within the fiction that he has helped him create
that is Samsung has step create another fiction for or don't for Doki holder,
which is really not a fiction.
Uh,
that is that Doki Quixote is a great night.
Aaron already the object of a book.
So He uh,
in beause Don Quixote with this idea,
you are great character already,
you know,
in a,
in a book.
So you have to act accordingly
in part to Samsung is the main author within the book.
See the I made,
they've been in was a distant author at least thrice removed by translators and
transcribers
sound song and others like the dukes steward whom you will meet soon enough,
we'll be authors within the fiction.
We read a new script,
the action and watch it unfold most of the time,
not like they intended it to
as author figures,
they are,
but particularly sounds song quite complex and modern.
Their intentions are rarely match the results.
Okay.
Much of the fun of the,
uh,
of the humor in part two is following the elaborate schemes of internal authors
that go awry with the opposite of what they have planned actually happens.
Some of them spectacularly.
This has much to say about other ship,
about the creation of fiction and about Cervantes,
his own creation of the fiction of the Quixote.
Okay.
I see that it is quite a modern conception of the author because this is the
conception that we have in the modern period of authors.
The whole of deconstruction,
the famous literary movement that was mostly started here at Yale.
I had to do with fine deconstructing authors,
uh,
making their intentions,
showing how their intentions rarely ever matched the results.
But that is another story.
Now,
uh,
Santo and,
and,
and Teresa.
Oh No,
let me,
uh,
so in,
in the hands of Samsung and other readers of part one,
the action in part two is poised between the past,
their remembrance of part one and the future,
their scripts based on it.
So it's poised in that like a balancing act between the past part one and the
future in this scripts that they have,
uh,
they delayed repair.
Hence it is like an action that unfolds in the present.
I said it's been written or just after following scripts whose development we as
readers can more or less follow.
Part two is a text in the making.
We learn these quite early in chapter five in the episode when Joe goes home to
convince his wife that he must accompany,
don't be haughty.
Again,
this is an issue that I,
an episode that I discussed briefly at the end of my last lecture,
but I want to revisit today.
Okay.
So the question of translation and improvisation resurfaces here.
Chapter Five,
part two begins in your translation,
the translator of this story coming to ride.
This fifth chapter says he takes it to be apocryphal because in its central
talks in another style that can be a,
that could be expected from a shallow understanding and says such subtle things
that he reckons impossible,
that he should know them.
Nevertheless,
he will not know bid,
translating them to comply with the duties of his office.
And so went on saying on the chapter begins
a little further,
it is again reported quote this kind of language and what central says further
below made the translator of this story.
Uh,
say he takes his chapter to be apocryphal.
Let us step by step brick construct or the comment by the translator at the
beginning of chapter five suggests about the status of the texts that we read.
But keeping in mind that all of these gains of authorship and textuality do not
lead to an ultimate ultimate coherence.
We cannot really pin down Cervantes on the issue of authorship.
How many authors are translators and we cannot pin him down either on which is
finally the text.
The text exists,
supposed to be in the original in a form that seems to be apocryphal.
That is that it is false.
Either a bogus addendum by somebody else,
uh,
or a falsifying re re writing of it.
They see the dometic write it this way or was it falsify in subways so that
sanctuary is talking like this.
Then it is translated into the text.
We read by a reluctant translator who alludes to his falseness but decides
nevertheless to translate and transcribe it,
but adding a note about his falsity,
it is a text that is erased.
I said it's been written and that should disappear as we read it.
Moreover,
there is a question of temporality.
When does it exist and in what form?
The answer is that it only exists at the moment of each reading.
This is I think a model of how the entire of part two exists.
Poised,
as I said,
between the remembers of part one and the future actions,
action actions scripted by the internal authors of part two actions that don't
turn out to be quite like the script.
Furthermore,
the translators admonition raises the issue of me Macy's,
which son is the real one?
Is it the one he remembers from part one or the new century who has evolved
improving his speech and endowed with the desire for social advancement,
not just for wealth.
The translators,
quip reveals at Centro has changed.
That is not static.
In fact that reality in general is not static and true me Macy's to be very much
aware of the changing nature of things and people.
So there is a,
uh,
an inherit provisional major to the text that we read and to the whole of part
two.
As we chat,
I'll suggest later.
It's part of it's baroque nature.
It is clear that here essential is playing the role of [inaudible] in this
chapter and his wife that of himself as he used to be.
This is hilarious,
which is why he corrects her mistakes when she misspeaks.
He's echoing donkey halters ideas re revealing that he has been quick.
So taste,
but also that he has acquired new values.
All this comes out in the discussion of their daughter's marriage,
which are,
they are discussing,
uh,
from,
different points of view.
Uh,
she wanted him to wanting her to marry her equal and central wanted her to marry
somebody of higher thoughts of the sun and,
and,
and so forth.
Santo social ambition is reflected in his intellectual improvement and swagger.
In part two of the key holder,
Sanjay will play a more central role and proved himself to be capable of things
that would not have been thought possible by the sanctuary of part one.
The changes in central his elevation in status have an ideological dimension as
well as an aesthetic.
One the poor and humble can learn and advance and novelistic characters move up
and down the social ladder.
This element of the Quixote,
which is a political element to anticipates the enlightenment and ideas that
lead to concepts about social leveling that will eventually lead to modern
conceptions of democracy,
but it also has a profoundly Christian background.
We Can Recall Matthew's Gospel,
Chapter Five,
the opening of the opening words of the sermon on the mount.
I quote,
bless it.
These are the beatitudes.
Blessed are the poor in spirit for theirs is the Kingdom of Heaven.
Blessed are they that mourn for they shall be comforted.
Blessed are the meek for they shall inherit the earth on quote.
If characters in novels will evolve,
they do.
So within a social context.
So this is consonant with the political character of the novel,
but this has also much to do with the development and evolution of realism in
literature,
particularly in the novel.
This brings me to oric our back.
I gave you a handout that happens to be a
happens to be an obituary note.
Oh,
you haven't,
you don't have it yet.
Happens to be an obituary note written by none other than when a Welock Renee.
Well,
it was a great professor here at Yale for many years.
The founder of the discipline of comparative literature in the United States.
Uh,
it's so happens that all of the,
all of the professionals and critics that I will be mentioning in my lecture
today,
where Yale professors,
uh,
Yale has been at the forefront of literary studies for many,
many years.
And this is a reflection of it.
I didn't plan it this way,
but it's so,
uh,
it's so happens.
So if you have a chance,
read that obituary,
uh,
a note,
but I'll give you a thumbnail sketch of our,
our bark and his theories in now the critic who put forth this theory about
Christianity and the development of realism was a rig hour back
in his outstanding book,
me,
Macy's,
the representation of reality in Western literature.
First published in the original German in Switzerland in 1946,
the year after World War,
uh,
the end of World War One.
We will be,
uh,
talking about him,
next week when you read his essay in the case book,
which is drawn from the book me,
Macy's about the enchanted do scenario.
Our back,
uh,
this is my,
my thumbnail sketch of our back.
Uh,
who was Jewish,
was born in Berlin.
He was trained in the German philological tradition and would eventually become
along with Leo Spitzer,
who we will also meet in the case book,
one of his best known scholars after participating as a combatant in world war
and World War One,
he earned a doctorate in 1921 and in 1929 became a member of the philology
faculty.
At the University of Marburg polishing a well-received story called Dante poet
of the secular world book that is still is red with the riots with the rise of
Nazism.
However,
our bank was forced to evacuate his position in 1934 he was thrown out because
he was Jewish exile from Nazi Germany.
He took up residence in Istanbul,
Turkey where he wrote me Macy's generally considered his masterwork and one of
the best books of literary criticism of the 20th century.
He has said in a moving a statement that uh,
he,
he wrote such a general book because,
uh,
in his temple he did not have his books or his,
the journals that he needed.
So he just went for the big works in Western literature and uh,
so it was this terrible circumstances that had the happy result of me Macy's,
our back move to the United States in 1947.
First Teaching at Pennsylvania State University and then working at the
Institute for advanced study in Princeton in 1950.
He was made sterling professor of romance languages at Yale,
the position that he held until his death.
While here being a professor in 1957 he died in,
in Wallingford.
Uh,
I'd have to say that as a holder myself over sterling chair here and yeah,
like I feel honored and humbled to have a precursor like our back who's working
memory.
I cherish the main,
the main idea of me Macy's,
a broad and profound one is about the Christian mixture of the sublime and the
low style in the new testament leading up to the emergence of realism,
the representation of everyday life and common people in serious literature.
We take this for granted now,
but it was not so until the new testament,
this was a break away from the strict distinction
between high and low style in the classical tradition by which the serious Java
like epic and tragedy dealt with outstanding figures including gods and was
written in a high rhetorical style where common speech had no place.
Whereas the minor John has like comedy dealt with low class people who speak in
vulgar speech and are invariably comical.
Our back derived his idea
from Saint Augustine and the church father.
The church fathers were those who during the Middle Ages wrote comments on
scripture and expanded and deepened the Christian,
uh,
Christian doctrine.
They include,
uh,
major philosophers like Saint Thomas Aquinas who wrote in the 13th century.
There are Greek fathers and Latin fathers.
I mean,
there is a patrol that is the writing of the fathers in Latin and another one
in,
in Greek Auerbach labels,
separable set Amo Amelie's humble sermon.
Okay.
This Christian responds to the crystal,
to the classical separation of styles,
which was derived from Aristotle and Roman rhetorical theory.
That separation of style was derived from Aristotle on Roman rhetorical theory.
The mixture of the transcendent and the low style is exemplified by Christ's
passion through which the quotidian drama of mankind everyday drama among
assumes more profound meaning life does not end in the brief span of worldly
existence.
Eternity is present in it as a message of hope.
Seth Lehrer,
uh,
writes about our buck,
our,
our back fines and apparently low or humble diction pressed into the service of
transcendent spirituality.
Developing an argument of Augustine's here on the power of the Christian word,
stripped of the trappings of classical eloquence.
Auerbach sees the progress of late antique and Medieval literature as moving
inexorably doors.
The synthesis of the humble and the sublime.
What could say that the Kihatha in bodies such a synthesis of the humble and the
sublime Auerbach's that that to Vico Giambattista Vico he has a very nice brief
name,
easy to remember.
It is a great Italian philosopher of the 18th century,
uh,
have been burnt out to show his understanding.
Vico Vico found that,
that,
uh,
the stories,
the literature,
uh,
the law over people are very much a part of their culture and a,
and has a,
a philosophy.
I'm just simplifying this,
that is very compelling because he says,
the basic argument is that humans understand only that which was created by
humans,
not by God's.
Therefore,
he has the story of mankind begin not with geneses,
but after the flood,
when man remakes on his own,
the world,
uh,
this is just a so that you can read vehicle someday,
as an enticement.
But of course it's a simplification.
Um,
now you will see all of this inaction.
I don't understand much better the essay on the enchanted do scenario,
uh,
with this background.
Having said that,
that chapter on the hot day is a very polemical one.
Uh,
that was very badly received by Hispanics standby Savantas scholars and it was
added to me Macy's later because of through his,
uh,
study of the mixture of styles.
Uh,
our back comes up with the idea in the end that I think is very questionable
that the Quixote is mainly,
or essentially a comical book,
but we will get to that after you've read that,
uh,
that essay on a chapter that you will have read by then or are reading now that
he learned those chapter,
uh,
who in Santo tries to convince Don Quixote that this winches that come on from
Dunkley's,
uh,
includes dual scenario and a,
and a,
it's an episode that I will be discussing,
uh,
laters and episode that always makes me laugh.
Every time I reread it.
I,
uh,
no matter how many thousands of I love particularly one Dorothy Holder reports
that the alleged Dulcinea smelled of raw garlic.
Um,
that he was,
uh,
this made by this.
But when you get to talk about that,
but that's part of the humble,
you see,
that's part of the realism that has to do with a comic on the humble and so
forth.
Okay.
So I have been,
uh,
anticipating ideas about the renaissance and the Baroque I need is time that we
begin a more focused discussion on this period of Western art and literature is
useful to be able to place a workload.
The Chiota within this periods of art and literature.
It is,
it cannot be the goal of our readings.
It's because it's something that helps our enjoyment and understanding of his
books.
But,
uh,
work such as Hipaa does not explain it away,
but no first to have a clear chronological notion.
Little say that the renaissance cover covers from the 14th or 15th century and
the Baroque,
the 17th century and parts of the 18th.
So we could have a scheme,
let me see.
I was thinking of how to,
how to,
how to say this is all going to be very simplistic,
this middle ages and then from the 14th.
So you're not gonna make it at least readable,
uh,
15th
and 16th centuries
parts of it.
This is the renaissance
and from here through the 18th
is the borough,
which the has the further development is what he called the Rococo in one of my
quotes then,
well,
it will mention German expressionism at the beginning of the 20th century
expression issue.
This is a,
do you have an idea?
Okay.
Uh,
so,
uh,
so the Rana sounds cover is that from the 14th and the 16th,
the for the 14th to the 16th century,
uh,
and the Baroque from the 17th century through the 18th,
the renaissance as we have seen is the period when Western thought breaks away
from medieval ideas and practices which were centered on religious doctrine and
humanists attempt to revive the classical age Greek and Roman arts and ideas.
It is a more secular period in which neoplatonism is one of the principle trains
of thought.
Basically the idea of achieved through love and the possibility of achieving
perfection by imitating the harmonious forms of classical art.
That is an inherent optimism in the renaissance and in humanism in general.
Because it is hoped that the revival of the classical past,
we'll Rianna mate revive the present and bring back a golden age as we saw
expressed by Don Quixote's speech.
Also,
there is a confidence there is confidence in human agency and the ability to
bring about perfection to the practice of classical norms.
You Tapia is one of the renaissance ideas and ideals which gain concretion in
Thomas [inaudible] famous book Utopia,
the perfect society.
It's attainable through the application of rational,
rational norms.
There can be a perfect ruler as prescribed by Machiavelli,
the prince,
and a perfect Kurt here as described by Castiglione in the book of the culture,
uh,
and even a perfect night as presented in the romances of chivalrous 14th 15th
century.
Nature and his representation can be harmonious and beautiful.
Perfect beauty is available in nature and attainable in art.
They buy.
Rock on the other hand is an age in which disappointment with these ideas and
aspirations are expressed and the perfect forms of the renaissance are twisted
and turned to generate a complicated convoluted form of art that has often been
seen as the blending of renaissance forms with gothic ones.
By looking back to the Middle Ages,
therefore they buy rock would be
turning this renaissance neoclassical forms back to the Middle Ages on to uh,
the uh,
uh,
the gothic.
Think of the gothic cathedrals like that and think of classicism,
US building
like that.
This is all very simplified,
but I want you to have clear ideas which you can then complicate where there,
where there is light in the renaissance.
There is darkness or at least [inaudible] the word that I introduced you to
before in the baroque and mixture of darkness and light discussions of the
priest and the barber with Gnocchi.
Haughty seemed to center on the disappointments of the age along with the game
of illusions.
Part two is going to be that of Baroque,
this in Ganja
word that I mentioned before that I'm going to mention again today and discuss
in some detail.
Okay.
When the games brewed to be nothing more than that,
games have illusions.
Renaissance optimism gives way to baroque this illusion man.
The commonplace then is that part one of the Quixote belongs to the renaissance
and part two to the Baroque.
Think of the two ages that Elliott spoke about in that quote that I read to you
from the book,
one of imperial expansion and another of imperial retreat.
This is an oversimplification of course,
but there is enough truth in it to merit consideration.
So I will devote some time to the concept of Baroque today.
In general,
what is understood,
what is understood by Baroque in general,
people have a general idea,
a vague idea.
This is very baroque.
You mean by that is something very complicated,
needlessly complicated.
Uh,
Webster's definition is good enough,
irregular in shape like some Paris,
actually the name Baroque comes with the names of some irregular Paris,
Paris,
artistically irregular in Congress or fantastic
as a style of architectural.
And other decoration of the 17th and 18th century,
tasteless Lee,
odd,
bizarre,
and grotesque.
You do not want to be called Baroque.
Some of his features are excessive accumulation,
difficulty,
obscurity,
and literally darkness.
Carroll school.
A good example,
a good example is Bernini's Saint Teresa in ecstasy.
Oh,
you have a problem of Chiaroscuro here,
okay.
Where one sees the effects of the spiritual or the physical,
which cannot express the sublime feeling of union with God.
You can see she said,
ecstasies and the falls over clothing,
uh,
express,
this sublime feeling of union clothing,
expressing mood by his foals body covered except for the hand and the foot.
Like I see a foot there on the face.
Of course,
in that moment of ecstasy,
this is certainly not a renaissance,
uh,
statute.
Uh,
think of a Michelangelo,
the David,
something like that.
This is not because of,
of it's twists and folds and,
and,
and so forth.
This is a,
a better Nini,
uh,
stature,
typical of the Baroque.
Another good example is Antonio Perez,
the Cavaliers Dream,
uh,
where the ephemeral nature of the reel is emphasized.
And of course,
the,
the Baroque,
uh,
emphasizes,
images of death and of decay.
So his,
uh,
turns into a theater death,
books,
uh,
and so forth.
This is a baroque dream that this,
uh,
that this,
cavalier,
uh,
is having his name is,
by the way,
I'm Tonio pay data and the previous one is Bernini.
Um,
so I wanted you to have those,
but I'm going to give you some more examples that are close at hand.
So let me comment on a few quotations on the Baroque.
The first one is from Jose [inaudible],
who was also a professor at Yale for many years.
The alien and professor.
He died about two years ago at age,
about 98.
Uh,
he wrote,
it is generally agreed today that the Baroque was in Europe and artistic climate
created by the spiritual climate of the counter reformation.
Now you know what the counter reformation is having where Elliot,
that movement in Spain that counter the reformation in the rest of Europe,
mostly Germany,
uh,
the council of Trent and all of that,
I go on with this climate acted like I was like an obscure force that pushed
Dorthy return to what it was before the eruption of the renaissance because
return back to the middle ages
to jump back to grounds that because they had not been turned,
appear to be more secure in this job back.
Europeans constrained by the landscape of their own history fell onto
intellectual and artistic currents that were aesthetically akin to the gothic
and intellectually to the Middle Ages.
The gothic,
my depiction there of the Gothic cathedral on quote,
I mean Spain,
the renewal of scholastic thought and the retrenchment brought about by the
counter reformation in general signify this and our uh,
and lead towards the,
the,
the rock.
Because I can be of course,
no returning history of what turns out is something completely new.
The,
the,
the mixture,
they very uneasy mixture of renaissance forms,
uh,
with medieval ones.
And that turns out to be,
then they will rock you.
I hope you follow this back and forth.
The next quote is from Bernay Welock,
uh,
whom I mentioned before,
a great professor of comparative literature here of check origin,
the concept of Baroque and literary scholarship.
This is a little more,
he's a little denser because he has to do with the,
with the critical concept of the Baroque.
What I want you to have an idea of it.
We're like traces the development of the term baroque above all,
it's transfer from art history to historiography.
The Tampa rock began as a term of art history.
He links to dissemination of the concept to the use of oss roles that that that
Osho Spangler makes over in the decline of the West.
The decline of the west by Oswald Spengler was a very,
very important book in the 20th century,
late twenties late teens,
early twenties who are 20th century,
the decline of the worst.
It was a book that was misused by the Nazis and so forth.
That was very powerful.
I see it as a synthesis of Hegel and Nicha,
but that's too much to,
to explain today.
Um,
on establish the relationship established with expressionism at the beginning of
the 20th century.
Welock thinks that the,
the,
um,
uh,
popularity of,
of the Baroque came because critics saw in expressionism,
which is a kind of poetry in Germany at the beginning of the 20th century,
in the 1920s,
very convoluted,
complicated poetry.
They saw that as a kind of return to the Baroque.
I hope this,
this very crude,
uh,
drawing of mine,
can help you visualize all of this
distinguishes between those who want to turn but rock into a typology.
That is that the whole of art history is a back and forth between renaissance
and Baroque.
Renaissance and Baroque is like all others who have tried to turn all of
literary history to Romanticism and the enlightenment,
a romanticism or neoclassicism he's,
he's,
he's against,
uh,
all of those.
Um,
and this is the most important quote.
See if I can unpack it for you.
The word here that is important is that big word there.
What is steam is fish Emmy's.
Synesthesia means to express
one,
uh,
um,
sense through another.
There is,
when you say,
oh,
it's a blue sound,
that's the same as this year or a shrill color shrill is sound and you apply it
to color that is same as Theseus is a,
it's a combination of sensations from various sensors,
a used one for the owner.
You understand what I'm trying to say?
Is that clear?
Okay.
For many other writers,
it would be possible to see an in an individual connection between the
emblematic image and their belief in the pervasive parallelism between
macrocosm,
the macrocosm in some vast system of correspondences which can be expressed only
by sensuous symbolism.
The prevalence of Synesthesia,
which in the renaissance apparently occurs only under such traditional figures
as the music of the spheres.
But during the Baroque boldly hears callers and see sounds in another,
you know,
is another indication of this belief in a multiple web of interrelations.
Of course,
uh,
correspondences in the universe.
What this means is the following in the Baroque,
there is an attempt to reconstitute the kind of unified conception of the
universe that was prevalent in the Middle Ages and that you see in Dante.
And that you see in the,
in the,
uh,
in the gothic cathedrals all center on the figure of the Christian God and in
all symbolism,
everything connected to it in a very harmonious and satisfying hole where
everything has a meaning and a place in the baroque,
this set of correspondences tries the right are some of the act.
The artists try to reconstruct the set of correspondences.
But this is a world that is no longer centered.
Remember,
it's a word that is post Copernican and he's,
he's a,
it's,
it's a word you're in which a Galileo is producing his theories.
And so he said decentered world.
So the Baroque is an effort through synesthesia that is to express the
correspondence was between colors and sounds,
uh,
and,
and so forth to reconstruct through art that um,
uh,
set of correspondences that harmonious world that is no longer a available.
And this is what gives the baroque this a tension.
Okay.
The way that I explain that the renaissance and Baroque is think of Binaca Plaza
Binaca Plaza with this columns.
Uh,
it's uh,
like the renaissance only got eight is an 18th century kind of neoclassicism.
But think of it,
it is a,
uh,
that kind of classical shape.
Sterling Memorial Library is Gothic neogothic.
Okay.
Neogothic uh,
I often say that the Mcdonald's arches more genuine don our neogothic,
but nevertheless it's neogothic and so they have a rope would be a very eh
forced combination of Beinecke Plaza and Sterling Memorial Library.
That would be,
uh,
the,
the barrel.
Now the baroque now in parts one and two of the chaotic,
we have spoken about Baroque elements in part one,
but particularly the grotesque in characters like a merito torness the play of
illusion and reality and the multiplicity of fictional levels.
The Carroll school,
all the episodes in the,
in the 19 self,
which is to cruise a combination of things to go test combination thing,
but part of one's still contains many elements of what could still be called
renaissance.
This is so particularly in characters which as Marcella and Dorothea whose
beauty and perfection reflect neoplatonic ideas.
The same is true of some of the settings,
particularly the locals are menus that I've mentioned several times.
We're doterra appears washing her feet in an episode in which the classical
background seems to be derived from orbit.
As Tony reminded me once and I didn't give him credit for this is uh,
uh,
an obedient scene,
and the rewriting of classical models is very much a renaissance feature by the
way,
nature present because so much of part one takes place outdoors appears to be
plenty for an orderly except when [inaudible] gets a sudden and unexpected
sexual urge and provokes a row.
As we remember,
there is also a kind of underlying sense of optimism and mirth in part one.
Even when Gnocchi hope this return home in a cage which was which had something
kind of a left about it.
Remember that he gets home on a Sunday
and after all the various amorous conflicts are resolved except for the last one
whose resolution is not clear because it's still going on the we withdrawals to
Fernando and seen that we've got Daniel.
The captive is going to Marisol either Lewis,
Clara and so forth.
Don't holders interventions have an affirmative effect in the end.
The commonplace about this is that renaissance aesthetics are based on an idea
of order,
symmetry and perfection obtained by the mutation of classical models and the
striving for humanly attainable goals.
Human agencies,
self fashioning,
straight angles,
horizontal lines meeting vertical ones ordered repetition,
the columns,
all these are renaissance feature.
The repetition of all the stories.
It's like those columns.
Part two however,
is going to be much more baroque.
I have already said that much of it takes place within buildings and that it is
generally darker.
There is a Carroll school quality to it and the Chiaroscuro as I have been
saying,
it's typical of the Baroque.
There are more grotesque elements made up of the disparate,
the contrasting and the ugly.
Here,
the key figure about which I will be speaking in other classes is the monster is
going to take place.
Uh,
part two is going to take place,
not in India or in nature,
but in lavish country and urban houses they were rogue tends to be built up to
be complex.
In part two.
We have not so much nature as architecture or what I like to call arch texture,
a texture that is intensified.
Therefore arch texture.
The multiplicity of fictional levels is going to increase by the fact that the
characters now,
uh,
no and discuss part one and by the appearance of again Neda's Apocryphal Quixote
is central theme and narrative device of part two is going to be disengaged.
Knew this illusion meant which could be the overarching direction and shape of
the plot.
In fact,
one could say that the whole of part two is leading to death and Ganja.
This is going to be the end of part two.
Uh,
and this end Ganja is perhaps the most important element of the Spanish Baroque.
I am going to leave it there except to point out that I have given you in the,
in the,
uh,
in the handout with the map of Spain behind you will see a quote from our grassy
ants,
l critical me,
which is a definition of design Ganglia that I'm going to begin the next lecture
with as I applied to the evolution,
the unfolding of the plot of the Quixote.